hi i'm christopher hine and today we're
going to talk about joe nage and i'm
going to give you a real simple
progression i use for joe nage joe nage
just means throwing with the joe so if i
had a joe and someone was
grabbing it or trying to get it from me
how would i project them off of me
i'm going to start with a really simple
set of ideas and we're going to build
from there i'm going to kind of talk
about the concept of index so if some of
that seems confusing you can watch the
video i made on index
but basically uh the there are some root
core things you're going to do that are
really simple that are in the forms but
are kind of hard to pull out of the form
sometimes if we're not looking at the
forms right so that's we're going to
work on today is joe nagy i'm gonna call
josh over here we're gonna go to work
josh
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so we're gonna look at a
little joe nage joe nage just means
projections with the joe so if i had the
joe how would i use that to project him
away if he grabbed my joe right um so
thank you very much so important thing i
should switch sides so i can be in
regular skeek my for this okay so
if i had a weapon and i'm trying to keep
this guy away one thing he can do to
threaten my use of the weapon is just to
grab the weapon right so that's one
thing he definitely can do and that's
bad for me i want to
not have that because i want to use the
weapon right to whack him and stick him
in all kinds of stuff keep distance all
the other stuff all right now the first
concern you should have when someone
grabs your weapon is that if they get it
with one hand almost immediately after
two hands are going to come on now it's
much harder to deal with two hands in
one hand and i know that's obvious but
it needs to be said because i would love
to deal with this when he just gets it
with one hand okay so i should always be
working away from that hand meaning i
should try not to work this way because
it just makes it quicker for him to grab
it i should always try to work this way
which takes a little longer for him to
grab it right i don't have infinite time
of course but i'll get a few more
seconds so always head to the outside
with these and try not to head to the
inside now that's situationally
dependent right so meaning if i was
being attacked by another guy here i
would choose to move that way even
though josh would maybe get two hands on
it because i don't want to go into this
guy because that's going to give me a
lot of trouble
so that's my first idea now the first
thing i want to do is how simply can i
get it off and basically nico and kota
guys are going to be your your go-to
tools for that right so to do that i'm
either going to go this way there's
enikyo or i'm going to go this way
there's a kodakaish okay now depending
on the index i catch him in
depends on what i can do with this right
so meaning if i catch him really early
right so maybe he's just going to grab
it and i'm getting it like this and so a
lot of the work's done i can take it out
that way really easily or same thing
sorry
the index is here and i'm getting here
and it's like if i'm right on top of it
meaning that i understand basically when
he's gonna grab it as he understands
he's gonna grab it okay now the later i
get the more locked down that's gonna
become to a point like this where it's
very locked down right and it's gonna be
hard to move and so if josh just resists
i can't really go either direction with
this right okay now
this is one of the things i think a lot
of times when when we show iketer
techniques something like this people
look at and they say oh well then the
technique doesn't work because if they
grab it as strong as they possibly can
grab but it doesn't work
we have to make adaptations as
people get stronger and we want to look
at all the times and not just one time
right so meaning i don't want to have to
always let him grab it as strong as
possible so i can do my strongest
possible technique i would like to have
got it at the index of him moving it all
right now
another thing to understand is that he
is probably going to move it out of his
way also he's not just going to leave it
there so he could pull it to the inside
for the outside for whatever reason or
you pull it to the inside for whatever
reason all right now if he does that so
let's say i'm behind an index and he's
grabbed it strong but he moves it either
to the outside that gives me a nico or
if he moves it to the inside that gives
me a coat of gauche right so i could
still even if he's grabbed it strong and
i can't move it i could be dependent
upon him to move it and still still work
and understand we're still talking about
tenths of seconds here because it's not
going to be long before that other hand
grabs or is hitting me or whatever so
another thing that will give me the
advan an advantage is to slide my hand
up to here and a lot of times we don't
talk about this but now i have a lever
that's this long right that's a long
lever over here i only have a lever
that's this long right so understand
that i'm really trying to inefficiently
use the weapon here whereas if i slide
my hand up i now have a ton of force
right and to josh that feels like
machinery all of a sudden right it
doesn't feel like a guy's wrestling with
you because this lever is so long this
feels like a machine's doing it to his
hand because it's just freaking strong
right so anytime you think that there's
trouble you should slide your hand in
next to his and that's going to start to
give me that advantage okay and again
i'm going to be working my nico and my
coat of gosh primarily because those are
going to be my best chances to escape
this
now if i get in here and he's locked it
down and not moving at all and
understand i'm doing all this right now
just because i don't want to track the
camera around
but we're moving in this right because
he's going to be trying to come in and
get it with that other hand and i'm
going to be trying to get away from that
with that other hand so we're moving
around right now i'm just showing this
this way so you can see it but i've slid
up here and even with the mechanical
advantage he's totally locked out and
this is quite possible i just i still
can't get it right all right i have a
couple options to attack his hand one is
to go into any kind of yonkyo right so
meaning i could roll yonko and you can't
see it right now but i just rolled
yonkyo right up here on top of his
knuckle and so now when i grab and drive
into it i can put a ton of force right
into that knuckle makes him want to pull
his hand away quick now look it's not a
death grip but if it just hurts and it's
suddenly surprising natural reaction is
often to pull your hand out touch
something hot pull your hand back right
so so that is something i can go into
immediately so i could try yonko now i
could try my yonko there i could try it
on the metacarpals in the hand i might
be able to get to the thumb i might just
go to the wrist right but i can get
yonko anywhere in here and that's one
thing i'm going to try really quick can
i yonko him and see if he'll let go of
it now in addition to that i'm going to
try rokyo's especially if he's locked
out like this right so if he's locked
out like this i'm going to try to get in
there and get to the elbow and pop him
off with that rokyo and this works
perfectly with my idea of moving away
from that other hand coming in all right
now if i get in here and he bends his
arm i'm either going to get kodagaish or
shihonage depending on where he's at
right so both shionaga and the kotori
guys will come up when he pulls his arm
in like that if for some odd reason he
pulls his arm up high which could happen
right because maybe he felt that coming
on he didn't like it i have the nico
here and i have the sankyo here right so
both of those are a ton of power in that
and then also if we get close quarters
to that we'll get kokinage so let's say
we get in close like this and i can't
get those to work kokunage immediately
becomes available also in there juji
nage will become available because we're
here i hit the face and i drive in here
boom and there's my juji right there as
i drive this into him right so
the way i'm thinking of this progression
is the second i see him going to grab it
i want to move the joe into a position
that won't be beneficial to him those
basic positions are going to be kodagush
and nico and that's the way i'm working
now as long as i can do that so if he's
not resisting me that's what i'm going
to do right from where i'm at because i
don't want to reset this the second i
get resistance i'm going to slide my
hand in and start using my mechanical
advantage to help me all this is being
done away from him by the way and if i
can't get it there i'm going to try and
attack the hand or attack the elbow from
the elbow attack and the hand tech he
will give me different positions if i
can't get anything out of that i'll go
into basic nagewaza right which is i can
use kokinagi giuji nage all kinds of
other stuff will come up in there right
koshinage all kinds of stuff come up
there but that's the way i should be
thinking of this is get it before he
gets his second hand on now once he gets
his second hand on there's a bunch of
classic joe nage you'll see right so as
he comes in here and he grabs with the
other hand can i switch his direction so
see how i cross him there and that's a
variation on juji nage sometimes called
the cookie nugget sometimes called
nurimi naga depending on the style of
study aikido you study so as he comes in
can i cross that across like this and i
get him twisted up which is really
really a good thing for me okay if he
comes in and grabs can i go direct and
you see osensei doing this a lot where
he comes directly in and this is
sometimes called nodotsuki or it's also
called idimi nage sometimes i've also
seen it called kokinagi sometimes
depending on who the teacher is right so
those are my basic core ideas i'm going
to use when this guy starts to get the
second hand on as he comes here boom i'm
going to go to this position or if i
can't pull that way i'm going to try to
come in here and and get him off now if
he pulls or pushes me i get a bunch of
different options as well right so if he
comes in with that other hand and he
pulls me i can enter into that we get
cookie nuggets and eating me nages from
that if he comes in and he pushes me i
can take that push and i can turn it
into all kinds of other stuff variations
on coke quinoa etc so forth so this is
the way i think you should think
progressively about joe nage and instead
of trying to teach a form and think that
the form is all there is and i do think
you should teach the forms i think you
should you should realize that the forms
exist as a progression of ideas and i
would like to catch them as early as
possible i see his hand grab i'd like to
pull it away right so i would like to
see josh come to grab and go whoop sue
bet right and then his face is right
there bang and i get him so that would
be the highest index possible right i
understand the intent before he's even
gone into action but each stage i need a
set of techniques to how to as to how
i'm going to deal with whatever it is
he's up to so think of joe nage as a
progression of ideas instead of just a
form and if the form doesn't work well
then it doesn't work and aikido is no
good or jonah is no good or it's
impossible or all the other crazy stuff
we tend to think so that's a fair amount
about joe nage um i'm christopher hines
this is joshua teehee behind that camera
is maya solano mcdowell oh she got the
dance going again folks so dancing now
she's done and this is a defeated look
right she asked me the other day why i
call her out on camera because she's
there and i want you guys to know she's
there anyways thank you for watching
foreign